you guys I'm jumping right on in no I'm
good I really sincerely mean it thank
you so much for coming in the studio
today and also for people that are gonna
be watching this right now big thumbs up
to you guys on this film like it it's an
it absolutely feels like a bad-boy
sequel it feels like you know no time
has gone except it's been like 18 years
or whatever it is so I want to start
with the most important question for
each of you how much did you pay to work
with Will Smith in this film my entire
salary and then I it was a dream come
true I mean come on
bad boys I would pay to be in this film
which again that's why I'm asking you
yeah how much would I pay or how much
did I pay how much did you pay oh I did
it for free right got it
the agents are super f and mad at me
right now I am curious what is it like
did you guys get how did how did this
project land in your lap and is it one
of these things where like when you
start hearing about it you're like get
the F out of here
yeah like when I heard that they were
gonna do I mean I think it's been going
on for a few years right they've always
been talking about doing the third
installment of the bad boys and you know
when I heard it was coming out I didn't
really think anything I was like oh this
is amazing this is a franchise I grew up
with this is a franchise that's very
something that I idolized growing up
especially with more on Lawrence and
Will Smith and I remember when I got the
audition it kind of surreal like I
didn't think anything of it and the next
thing I know I'm testing with Alexander
and Vanessa and with belonging a doe and
yes and Jerry Bruckheimer's life office
which was insane and Doug Belgrad Chad
like very surreal man very surreal yeah
to echo what Charles said I would I
would have to agree I mean it you know
the the great thing about this this
industry is the only way to succeed is
to just keep throwing your hat in the
ring you know and hope you know you
state you stick around the barbershop
long enough your
get a haircut right and I like with this
in specific I I really felt like it was
a long shot like for me I was like you
know I mean I'm gonna do my thing and
we'll see what happens you know it was
one of those things and it's funny how
it always works you're consistently
humbled in this industry we're the ones
that you always think that you're you're
right for you might get you don't end up
getting and then the ones that you
didn't expect usually pleasantly
surprise you and this film was was
certainly one of those instances where
just you walk on set and you're just
like what am i doing yeah this is just
amazing and then and then reality hits
you and it's like okay it's go time
let's let's let's bring this home
because we have a job to do and yeah and
I want to make this the best movie it
can possibly be and to hear you say
because I hadn't seen I hadn't seen the
film yet to hear you say that that you
felt like you saw a bad boys movie is
the greatest compliment we possibly
could have gotten because that's exactly
what we were going for really we want
this to feel authentically like those
films that we we loved growing up and
with a new energy to it completely how
you both have worked on a number of
different things at this point how
nervous are you the night before an
audition like this and how much are you
in your head thinking do you know what I
mean are you overthinking things when
you're gonna audition for a big project
or are you sort of like it is what it is
I think specifically with you know bad
boys you're you're excited for the
opportunity to go in and do your work
but also you're just like you know like
Alex said like throw your hat in the
ring you know you this is you kind of
just like let it go I mean for this I'll
just like okay it's bad boys like this
is probably not gonna happen but I'm
gonna do my best work like mean a bad
boys movie yeah right and you go in
there and this is something liberating
about that just letting go and yeah it
was very surreal and I think that it's
like a it's a trap really and I think
you learn over time as an actor but also
as a human being it just be grateful for
where you're at in this one moment and
it's such a trap to start fantasizing
about all the possibilities that
any job could bring you down because
then if you don't get the part not only
have you lost the part but you've lost
everything that you thought that part
was gonna bring you you know whatever it
is so I think that once you get to that
place of just like like Charles said I'm
gonna do the best work I possibly can
I'm gonna leave it out to the universe
and whatever happens happens
that's when beautiful things really
start to have you and always always
operating through gratitude you know and
on that note I'm so grateful to be a
part of this film it's it's unbelievable
and I don't think I've ever been more
excited for a release in my life
I like always asking about specific
stuff in a movie so if you don't mind
both of you there's a photo right there
on that yeah so let's talk about
specifically that scene and what do you
guys remember from filming us so Charles
had just posted something like I think
it was like a nude of him on Instagram
and we're all just like what the hell
did you just do that's so embarrassing
it does look like he is debating like
what did I just post tags do I look like
it's confused and a little bit more
intrigue than I'd like okay but yeah in
all seriousness in the context of the
film this is we're in Mexico and were
where we're about to do a dog here right
yeah huge raid and we're kind of just
scoping the whole blueprint of the area
just kind of like trying to set a game
plan of what we're about to do yeah and
this thing is it one of those things
look I've spoken a lot of actors and
some actors love to like amp themselves
up before I take and some love to listen
to music and some need to be completely
silent
obviously everyone works a different way
how do each of you like to work and how
was it on how did everyone else you know
what I mean like the way everyone likes
to work on set I mean yeah for me it's
just like cuddles from my from my
passed around me is like super helpful a
lot of hugs a lot of hugs and cuddling
the four scenes I never know if you guys
are being serious now
no no in all seriousness for me like I
mean you know an actor prepares if you
want to be from me Percy and I think
that the fun great thing about acting is
that everybody has their own process and
what works for them there's no right way
to do it but for me like preparation is
key so it's breaking down the scene
before you get to set it's getting my
notes down it's getting all my ideas
down and and making those those
unexpected choices and seeing what
sticks you know and the great thing
about it Dillon below you know is that
is that they gave you that room to to
really play and let your characters
evolve and and and and you know some
stuff makes it and some stuff doesn't
and and that's that's the beauty of this
and once you see it all come together
you're watching it for the first time
like everyone else because you have no
idea what they ended up with the ended
up choosing you know it's it really
comes down to the preparation it's like
the research and I think for specific
days or projects or scenes like you know
whether you need to be completely silent
or listen to music or knock out a few
push-ups whatever you have to do to get
there and I especially the environment
that we were working with the Dylan
Bilal like they like Alex I'm saying
they really kind of set the tone and you
really felt like you're in this world in
this bad boys world and things just came
organically and you know there's a lot
of freedom to collaborate and to throw
things in and change things up to you
know really bring a kind of like a
foundation to each of our characters and
it was yeah I mean it was great you
obviously have spent a lot of time doing
TV with Riverdale you spent a lot of
time doing Vikings can you maybe explain
to people that aren't familiar about
what it's like making a TV series versus
a feature film and maybe how it's
different on set and you know what it's
like for each of you you know what I
mean yeah yeah it's a completely
different energy yeah I mean you know I
think when it comes to working on a TV
show like Riverdale it's such a great
show to be a part of it's
I think you know there's there's kind of
is there's a routine and a schedule that
we follow and like getting our shots and
whatnot but I think you know with with
doing bad boys things are changing
constantly
you know scenes the scripts like things
are changing constantly and there's more
everyone's I think there's more of a
collaborative process when it comes into
making a movie because everyone wants to
give their best work and they want the
best outcome possible so it's like what
can we do to amplify this scene what can
we do to make this better like what can
we add like what can we add Lib or what
not and I really don't think you have
that much freedom doing a TV show it
just depends on what you know show
you're doing but yeah that's very
different very different yeah I mean III
would agree with a lot of that too I
mean certainly the pace you know when
are you gonna show you've got you know
you know is from my experience from
Vikings yeah you're in you're in Ireland
in the elements rain or shine you're out
there because they're not calling it I'm
you know I think we've called that we've
called the day you know twice in my six
years of shooting in Ireland and four I
mean one of us because of a hurricane
like it's like if for the most part
we're making it out and we're gonna do
our scene and we've got you know three
scenes to shoot in a day and lots of
dialogue and and you've got to come
prepped and I honestly think for an
actor working on a TV show is one of the
greatest gifts possible it's like a
master class in in acting because you
just you have to show up and and there's
there's no excuses like you just gotta
make it you know if you're sick or
anything you got to be there because you
know it's everyone's time it's a lot of
money that's being on the table and then
conversely on something like bad boys
it's like it you know same obviously the
same situation you still gotta show up
and all this and but you get so much
more time to play especially with with
an action comedy like bad boys because
you know so much of the beauty of this
film comes from the unexpected and
things that aren't written down to begin
with and they know that you know well
and Martin I mean
they excel in that and Jerry knows this
as well and they give you that space
don't get me wrong I mean you're you're
still I mean if you're a Dillon bowl all
like you're still you're powering
through but there is a lot of room to
play and to be like hey what if we tried
this or maybe we should do this line or
just like or just you know screw with
people and just randomly throw in a line
here and there how they deal with that
and you never know what's gonna make it
90% of it I'd say doesn't make it but
then that 10% that does can be freaking
beautiful and can change the game I mean
most of the stuff at least from what
I've heard at least my character was
improv you know that that it was just
stuff that was just coming out
organically that I talked about to will
I'm Martin before the Charles and I
talked about doing before that we talked
to directors before so in that sense
it's very liberating you know and I mean
it's compared to Vikings for me
personally I mean bad boys is just like
a dream because like you just have that
time yeah just just you know is sit
around and shoot [ __ ] and try to figure
out you know it's not it's not I don't
know meanwhile meanwhile Jerry
Bruckheimer is like pulling his hair out
trying to figure out you know and Doug
and Chad but it you know for us
they created a wonderful environment to
be creative I have to ask you I'm gonna
switch into a few other things real
quick since I'm you know where there's
only so much time when did you two
decide you would only make movies
together because I believe you guys are
both in Swing coming up with you worked
with Michael Shannon yes yes so when
when did the agreement happen very much
bad words I think we made it we made it
formal or official right yeah Charles
came in and lived with me for a few
weeks and and that way I think was that
sealed the deal yeah yeah sorry
Josh came and lived with me for a few
weeks I think that that kind of sealed
the deal you guys really were roommates
for a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so who is the person who is
absolute like beyond messy and who is
the super clean one
is it The Odd Couple are you both
similar you know what my girlfriend also
is living with us so I think we both
filter
oh I think we're both pretty messy but
we had we can both be clean when we need
to be clean yeah but seriously oh how
did it work because you are in a movie
another film together yeah I know so you
did bad boys and then swing happened yes
we happened so when I saw Alexander was
attached to the script and then I read
the script and I loved it and I was when
you guys were rooming together no before
before we actually filmed it already
actually yeah and he shot me a text and
I was like you know I heard that you're
interested in this is a really very
funny text laugh out loud text I won't
repeat what the text said but uh yeah
and then love the script and Alexander
was telling me that he was thinking
about me and when he read the script and
it just worked out man and it's cool to
do a you know bad boys is completely
different than the kind of project we
did on this and it is just very cool to
work in a different kind of a different
element so to speak I mean back there
and like the key to like I think a
successful film is is a great obviously
a great story that connects with
audiences but also the people that that
were surrounded with yeah and not as a
tremendous actor so so immediately when
I read this script I thought about him I
was not the reason at all though it just
so happened that how did not happen I
would have said something because I
thought you were amazing but they had
already talked we're already talking to
Charles and I got a call saying then
looking at Melton for this other role
and I was like thank God I was actually
gonna say say something so it ended up
working out yeah we're there and it's
like you know it's a it's a real
ensemble you know and I'm yeah I mean I
was so grateful yeah man that was
amazing I think we'll probably do you
know any more movies at least I think
yeah yeah I really really hope so guys
just worked you know obviously with will
and Marga and then you just worked with
Michael Shannon yeah
so have you thought about playing the
lottery recently I know right yeah
seriously yeah it's just wondering it's
ridiculous
dude like this year for us I think I'm
just like what is happening yeah I also
listen I love Michael Shannon he's an
amazing actor I mean the thing about
Michael though is like he there's no
[ __ ] with him no none so what is
that like cuz you know wills more of
like a laugh like fun you know what I
mean and Michael is Michael unless you
experience a different Michael the
knives know a thousand percent but but
the thing about Michael is and he
actually really reminded me about one of
my other co-stars on Vikings is that is
that he's he's such an introvert like
like in the sense of when he's on set he
is he's so talked about somebody who's
processes may be a little different like
he's very quiet he's very in his own his
own groove but you you start talking to
that man uh he opens up yeah and he's
just he has such a good heart and he is
such an artist yeah like he he cares so
much about the talent and I mean you
give Michael a great to play and he gets
paid nothing and he'd do that for the
rest of his life and be happy yeah I
mean he's he's such a yeah force as well
you know I yeah we learned a lot yeah
being around someone of that caliber and
Will Smith you know two different fields
you know but both respected and just
mega talented at what they do and 2019
was a great year you know to be
surrounded by that you know you you want
to surround yourself with people not
just kind people but people that are
ambitious that have accomplished a lot
of things that you want to accomplish as
well so that was very grateful for that
man I have a few fun questions so we're
switching gears completely yeah
okay here we go what TV show would you
like to guest star on oh my god I mean
there's there's so much good television
right now it's the same I mean off the
top of my head I love a succession I
think it's a it's an excellent show I
mean there's shirts especially I guess
I'll do
the this show's over with but they just
had their finale but I would love to
guest on ballers what movie have you
seen the most I'm not I'm actually not
just saying this bad boys 2 is up there
as we have movies that I think since
because since I was a kid I'd watch so
many and then butch Cass sorry and then
God I'm an idiot
and then Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid I watch a lot of a movie I'd say I
watch bad boys a lot but I'd say a
Knight's Tale and the matrix debate i
watch The Matrix every day after fourth
grade when I got back from school that
was nice they just every day watch every
day after 4:00 with the bag of Cheetos
and lanes that's what I did fourth grade
I am the chosen one
what was the last thing that you binge
watched the morning show fantastic
really yeah so what you do you what's
that thing that we're watching where
like they do like the the couples that
go on like okay it's on it's on Animal
Planet and it really came out 2015 if
you haven't seen it old show is 2015
no 20 yeah I shouldn't be alive oh my
god it's a reality TV show true stories
about people who like just us barely
escaped death and I'm like I love going
camping and being outdoors and stuff and
like and so watching this and like
watching these these poor people get
into these crazy situations and living
through it is just no it's amazing dude
like people were like they're like first
date and they get stuff like like on a
mountain in Switzerland during a storm
and have to like whether it's like a Z
and in like this specific episode this
woman's thinking about cutting the rope
because he's going you know they're like
she's like she probably has to cut this
rope like she has to cut it in order to
survive and he hasn't come back up and
like there's no cell service there's
nothing and she the moment she's about
to cut it he shows up know about you do
you remember your first movie or TV show
crush oh yeah first movie crush
Armageddon was a live Taylor live to it
yeah yeah live Taylor Liv Tyler yeah
first crush
Liv Tyler first crush Armageddon the
scene where Ben Affleck has like a
little animal cracker and they're doing
a little pillow talk and it's like he's
like crawling up her body and stuff I
was just I love I think it was I mean as
far back as I can remember I was sure I
could fly something even earlier but but
at the time is in high school Alicia is
it Elisha Cuthbert yes it became French
for a second is it the girl next door
yes oh yeah my I was just like what yeah
this is aria yeah and I was probably
like in like oh great or something when
it came out me laughter and I was like
tell me everything like how was this was
actually an angel in real life too I'm
gonna go back on my answer was her name
she was the foreign exchange student
Natalia from American Pie Natalie oh I
know you're talking I can't I know
exactly I know you're talking about but
I'm blanking on the name right yeah
Shane and Elizabeth yes she and
Elizabeth
American Pie maybe yeah
yeah they're all like yeah okay I think
it is like you know my last thing of the
fun question okay kids making sure
because he watches this she's gonna hate
you if your name I think it's Shannon
Elizabeth I'm pretty confident okay
well I'm very confident channel isn't it
well once there's a good day
Natalia Natalia was that was I right no
Nadia no right my last fun question also
the girl from sorry road trip
no no not wrote chip what's the one that
he yeah that he like traveled all the
way I'm gonna find that person also with
Eurotrip if people don't realize which
is by the way a [ __ ] great movie but
Scotty doesn't know being son by Matt
Damon it's Matt Damon singing Scottie de
and his whole look screaming Scotty
doesn't know Kristen Couric from
Smallville yeah how did they get him to
do that you must be probably or no this
might have been used to me Morris man
you still Matt Damon but Matt Damon I
mean like that's his alleged man doing
those random key and the kami on that
Avengers movie where he plays Thor or
the small guy in the truck no no no he's
doing like the play Oh doing the play
you're right my bad yeah yeah yeah last
fun question is there anything that you
guys collect I'm a hoarder but if
there's one thing I can't say receipts
no one does that anymore just 20 20
letters not like cards about like
letters sends letters anymore I do ooh
got it to him yeah yeah like like my
girlfriend and I like for like a month
and a half had actually sent letters to
each other like and there's we actually
got them framed when we I'm sorry child
again
don't mean I do have wanna puke right
now just talking about it that's great
yeah for real uh collecting uh
I like sneakers I collect a lot of shoes
man you know what's funny the other
question I was gonna ask is what's the
most you've spent on sneakers or shoes
you have to be I'm up there the most
I've heard is 2500 have you broken that
I'm close to that got it
Wow was it on a pair of sneakers or
shoes sneakers was it so it's a vintage
pair mm-hmm that you bought on eBay or
one of the sneaker sites I had someone
go pick it up for me oh god it's always
a new pair yeah was it
Easy's no but I do have a few Easy's was
it because listen I've learned a lot
about sneaker culture recently is it
Nikes mmm-hmm were they like Jordan ones
or something
were they Jordan once mm-hmm really
mm-hmm were they new in the box or they
like super describe the condition
they'd been worn before Dada did it come
with the box and everything box yeah
yeah yeah they probably in one like one
or twice right so yeah have you worn
them or they sort of like framed on the
ramp Frank did you frame them didn't
frame them but it's just like you know
that special occasion or jurors kind of
like that metal that you have yeah so do
you know anything about sneaker culture
cuz I've really learned a lot recently I
bought my shoes freaking wall murders
[Laughter]
I'm like like I get it like everybody's
got to think like it's you know but I
know I don't know anything about sneaker
culture I will just tell you as someone
who's learned by Tracy at Nike hooks me
up thanks Tracy
know a lot about sneaker culture and
it's a it's a I mean there's a great
there's a sneaker con where everyone is
to paying cash did you heard about this
mmm-hmm yeah like this is we're off on a
tangent I'm so sorry everybody here but
pretty cool sneakers right here Oh off
whites chucks love these right so uh how
many do you own more than 100 pairs II
oh yeah easily I yeah I have
yeah I had see I had just I got 20 pairs
of new shoes last month yeah do you have
a hookup at Nike or converse or he's
just a dude dude his hookup wasn't
saying you know as Wayne great the guys
and absolutely was tuned for this it was
really cool but he got adidas to send
everybody on the team a pair of sneakers
like you got such a hook-up force to
choose another stand right yeah adidas I
love it did as man and they're in they
always collaborate with someone you know
they had like a mountaineering
collection they have a Bedford
collection they're always collaborating
with somebody and they released
different kinds of shoes every month man
no no it's a huge yeah huge thing and
the 4d shoes that they have printed now
where it's like the sole of the shoe is
4d print it's [ __ ] amazing does that
mean 4d 4d like it it they printed they
like print it in a machine and like the
sole of the shoe is like it moves yeah
it's like squishy it's hard to explain I
think it's fine it's for like for like
for comfort comfort yeah and it's just
like they're constantly making new
inventions with sneakers because the
it's like a I don't know how many
billions of dollars it is a year but
it's ever everyone wear shoes these are
so much obviously for more shoes but
there's so much money yeah yeah you know
also you know we got to go but the
Instagram thing I'm sure helps you know
wearing the shoes putting them on
Instagram away you know all that on that
note thank you both so much for coming
I'm like I just I don't understand where
you put 25 hundred pairs yeah I have
over a hundred pairs of shoes and like a
closet
yeah mic boxes and stuff on that note
sorry Congrats on everything day real I
hope is a huge hit for you guys and
thank you so much for coming here you're
awesome man thank you so much